其他人：还有没有了m
Other: Is there any more?
其他人：好
Other: Okay.
其他人：so
Other: So...
其他人：那你可以来选一个口味
Other: Then you can choose a flavor.
其他人：这是一个
Other: Here's one.
其他人：两个巧克力
Other: Two chocolates.
其他人：你要巧克力
Other: Do you want chocolate?
其他人：好呀那我们现在拍卖
Other: Alright, then we will auction it now.
其他人：还可以选口味
Other: You can still choose a flavor.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：还可以有选口味的机会
Other: You still have a chance to choose a flavor.
其他人：非常的宝贵
Other: It's very precious.
其他人：因为你后面不拍的话就买不到
Other: Because if you don't auction later, you can't buy it.
其他人：就没有办法选口味
Other: And you won't be able to choose the flavor.
其他人：那么我们依旧是一个币起拍
Other: So we will start the bidding at one coin.
其他人：但是我们历史参考价都是两个币
Other: But our historical reference price is two coins.
其他人：历史参考价是两个币
Other: The historical reference price is two coins.
Shure: 好有没有出价的
Shure: Alright, any bids?
其他人：来一个币啊
Other: Come on, one coin.
Shure: 一个币好
Shure: One coin, okay.
Shure: 两个币
Shure: Two coins.
其他人： 两个币
Other: Two coins.
Shure: 就是不让老板吃上饭是吧
Shure: Are you trying to starve the boss?
其他人：还有没有了
Other: Is there any more?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：还有没有了
Other: Is there any more?
其他人：好那就两个币
Other: Alright, then two coins.
其他人：好
Other: Okay.
其他人：很明显上面那个在市场上不受欢迎
Other: It's obvious that the one above is not popular in the market.
其他人：完了上面这个在市场不受欢迎那那
Other: Well, the one above is not popular in the market, so...
Alice:录着呢
Alice: It's recording.
其他人：坏了剩下感觉不好卖
Other: Oh no, the remaining ones seem hard to sell.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 剩下你自己吃吧
Katrina: You can eat the rest yourself.
其他人：鉴于你的这个麻薯的麻薯
Other: Considering your mochi...
Katrina: 这什么
Katrina: What's this?
其他人：麻薯
Other: Mochi.
其他人：我们可以可以等待时间检验一下
Other: We can wait for time to test it.
其他人：我们现在先拍这个纸杯蛋糕
Other: Let's auction this cupcake first.
其他人：这是一个新品
Others: This is a new product.
Lucia: 我决定偷走一个谢谢你
Lucia: I've decided to steal one, thank you.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕
Others: This cupcake.
Lucia: 哈哈谢谢你
Lucia: Haha, thank you.
其他人：它的优势在于它附赠一个纸杯
Others: Its advantage is that it comes with a paper cup.
其他人：这是一个非常环保的纸杯
Others: It's a very eco-friendly paper cup.
其他人：而且它这上面的草莓呢
Others: And the strawberry on top...
Lucia: 刚不是我刚咬了一个
Lucia: Didn't I just bite one?
其他人：个数比较多
Others: There are quite a few of them.
Lucia: 你可以问问大家吃不吃
Lucia: You can ask if anyone wants to eat it.
其他人：至少都是有两半草莓
Others: At least there are two half strawberries.
其他人：我们刚刚卖过的这个抹茶蛋挞
Others: The matcha tart we just sold...
Lucia: 吃吗买下的同学请大家吃
Lucia: Wanna eat? Those who bought it, share it with everyone.
其他人：上面只有半片草莓
Others: There was only half a strawberry on top.
其他人：呃同样
Others: Uh, similarly...
Lucia: 先放这吧
Lucia: Just leave it here for now.
Lucia: 一会想吃的时候可以吃
Lucia: Eat it when you feel like it.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕是一个币一个
Others: This cupcake costs one coin each.
Lucia: 我蘸一下
Lucia: Let me dip it.
其他人：但是两个币三个
Others: But three for two coins.
其他人：所以我们就可以任意的价格起牌
Others: So we can start the bidding at any price.
其他人：是一个币
Others: It's one coin.
其他人：买一个还是两个币
Others: Buy one or two coins.
其他人：买3个你可以请吗好
Others: Buy three and you can share, okay?
其他人：没人出价
Others: No one bids.
其他人：要留拍了大家都等着一小时吧
Others: We might have to wait for an hour, everyone.
其他人：大家等着一会儿吃饭呢都
Others: Everyone is waiting to eat later.
其他人：到点了5:40
Others: It's 5:40.
其他人：一个币来一个币
Others: One coin, one coin.
其他人：那你要要一个吗
Others: Do you want one?
其他人：啊啊好你们是一个一个卖的吗
Others: Ah, are you selling one by one?
其他人：我也可以两个币三个卖
Others: I can also sell three for two coins.
其他人：哈哈哈一个币一个两个币三个
Others: Haha, one for one coin, three for two coins.
Lucia: 你俩到底谁在以毒乱回哈哈
Lucia: Who's confusing everyone here, haha?
其他人：哈哈哈你你买不买
Others: Haha, are you buying or not?
其他人：两个币就是三个
Others: Two coins for three.
其他人：对我没有两个币
Others: I don't have two coins.
Lucia: 我去拿个纸吧
Lucia: I'll go get some paper.
其他人：你没有两个币
Others: You don't have two coins?
其他人：那你可以向世界银行贷一个
Others: Then you can borrow from the World Bank.
其他人：哈哈哈不信
Others: Hahaha, I don't believe it.
其他人：我先你
Others: I'll go first.
其他人：你是应该先确定一个币我再拍
Others: You should decide on one coin, then I'll take the shot.
其他人：不你可以一个币买一个
Others: No, you can buy one with one coin.
其他人：你也可以两个币买三个
Others: Or you can buy three with two coins.
其他人：两个币买三个
Others: Two coins for three.
其他人：好那你那你要给我两个币
Others: Okay, then you need to give me two coins.
修其他人：你只要给我两个币
Others: Just give me two coins.
其他人：我就可以把它送给你
Others: Then I can give it to you.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
其他人：好坏了下面还有一个
Others: Oh no, there's another one below.
其他人：完了哈哈哈
Others: Oh no, hahaha.
其他人：两个币买4个
Others: Two coins for four.
其他人：我觉得可以啊
Others: I think that's fine.
其他人：那也可以
Others: That's okay too.
其他人：那就那就两个币买4个吧
Others: Then let's go with two coins for four.
其他人：好我们薄利多销一下
Others: Okay, let's go for small profits but quick turnover.
其他人：那
Others: Then
其他人：那我可以把这个把这个盒子送给你
Others: Then I can give you this box.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
其他人：给你一个
Others: Here's one for you.
其他人：你是银行拿一个
Others: You take one from the bank.
其他人：你是银行大股东
Others: You're the major shareholder of the bank.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
Shure: 我觉得我们可以走一下
Shure: I think we can move forward.
Shure: 迅速销售
Shure: Quick sales.
Shure: 那改这东西没法卖了
Shure: This thing can't be sold anymore.
其他人：这东西卖的不能让他连盆直接端走
Others: We can't just let them take everything including the pot.
其他人：那大家就那个
Others: So everyone,
其他人：那我们可以一会再卖
Others: We can sell it later.
其他人：我们可以先中场休息一下
Others: Let's take a break.
其他人：我们甜品的部分在拍卖穿插当中进行
Others: We'll intersperse the dessert part during the auction.
Katrina: 直接room turo吧
Katrina: Let's go straight to room turo.
Katrina: 然后要吃饭了
Katrina: Then we can eat.
其他人：没TURO这个放在本来是第二个环节
Others: No, TURO was supposed to be in the second segment.
Lucia: 哎你眨了一个那个小眼睛
Lucia: Hey, you blinked.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:下一环念啥呀我
Alice: What's the next segment I should read?
Katrina: TUROTURO来吧
Katrina: TUROTURO, come on.
Shure: RUTO一下子
Shure: RUTO in a moment.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa
Shure: 参观房间
Shure: Let's tour the room.
Alice:我我没把那个梗去掉
Alice: I didn't remove that gag.
其他人：七八九我收你20%佣金
Others: I'll charge you a 20% commission.
其他人：不过分好不过分
Others: Not too much, right?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Alice:吃吧呀
Alice: Go ahead and eat.
Alice:绿色的没事
Alice: The green one's fine.
Jake:来我们TURO一下
Jake: Come on, let's give it a try.
SFSR4:TURO一下之后我们就倒眼镜了OK
SFSR4: After we try it, we'll pour the drinks, okay?
Lucia: 让我再去检查一下我的那个有没有掉
Lucia: Let me go check if mine fell.
Lucia: 这个可能是雨轩的吧我感觉
Lucia: I think this might be Yuxuan's.
Jake:每个屋子是你门票吧
Jake: Each room is your ticket, right?
Jake:要不咱哇
Jake: Shall we, wow.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 那我的那个闺房十十个
Shure: Then my boudoir, ten of them.
Katrina: 放过gas吧
Katrina: Let it go, gas it.
Katrina: 闺房 20 哈哈闺房
Katrina: Boudoir, 20. Haha, boudoir.
Katrina: 从一楼开始吗
Katrina: Starting from the first floor?
Katrina: 还是什么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure: 从二楼吧从二楼吧来吧
Shure: From the second floor, let's start from the second floor.
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Alright.
Katrina: 见见世面
Katrina: Let's see the world.
Lucia: 等一下他又掉了
Lucia: Wait, it fell again.
Katrina: 特意把被子给叠了
Katrina: I purposely folded the quilt.
Jake:好好行没关系
Jake: It's fine, no worries.
Katrina: 嗯一片清新
Katrina: Hmm, so fresh.
其他人：这么干净
Others: So clean.
Katrina: 刚整理的
Katrina: Just tidied up.
其他人：这么整洁
Others: So neat.
Katrina: 全全塞这里面了
Katrina: Everything's stuffed in here.
Katrina: 哈哈哈就是他给我们
Katrina: Hahaha, it's just he gave us...
Katrina: 就是可以
Katrina: It's just okay.
Katrina: 这是动物派对
Katrina: This is Animal Party.
其他人：挂画啊
Others: Hanging paintings.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 这当然不是我画的
Katrina: Of course I didn't paint this.
Katrina: 这我的杰利卡特
Katrina: This is my Jellicart.
Katrina: 那个是我自己抓的娃娃
Katrina: That one is a doll I caught myself.
Katrina: 就那天去
Katrina: That day we went
Katrina: 我们去嗯去游戏厅
Katrina: We went, um, to the arcade
Katrina: 我自己抓的娃娃
Katrina: I caught the doll myself
其他人：这狐狸一定要发给我个链
Others: You have to send me a picture of that fox
Katrina: 嗯这是动物party
Katrina: Yeah, it's an animal party
Katrina: 哈哈哈全部都是动物
Katrina: Hahaha, it's all animals
Katrina: 然后还有那个
Katrina: And then there's that
Katrina: 耶我连地毯都是草坪
Katrina: Yay, even my carpet is grass
其他人：好看的好看的确实好看的
Others: Looks good, looks really good
Katrina: 还有香薰是吧
Katrina: There's also incense, right?
Jake:第二轮游客
Jake: Second round of visitors
Tasha: 第二轮啊
Tasha: The second round?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
其他人：草坪草坪
Others: Grass, grass
Katrina: 当当当当
Katrina: Ta-da
Katrina: 换个四件套会更漂亮
Katrina: Changing the bedsheet set would make it prettier
Katrina: 呃我不知道我
Katrina: Uh, I don't know
Katrina: 我跟他买的时候没有商量
Katrina: I didn't discuss it with him when I bought it
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah
Katrina: 哎呀我全是动物
Katrina: Oh man, it's all animals
Katrina: 看见没有
Katrina: See that?
Katrina: 噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Ta-da
Katrina: next room
Katrina: Next room
Katrina: nextroom可漂亮了
Katrina: The next room is super pretty
Jake:大家准备好
Jake: Everyone get ready
Katrina: 多巴胺风格
Katrina: Dopamine style
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Come on
Katrina: 索
Katrina: So
Katrina: 塔
Katrina: Ta
Katrina: 什么叫索塔
Katrina: What's sota?
Katrina: 就是目前最好的
Katrina: It's the best right now
Katrina: 哦索塔是吗
Katrina: Oh, is it Sota?
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Katrina: 你的真的很漂亮
Katrina: Yours is really pretty
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow
Lucia: 哇好可爱
Lucia: Wow, so cute
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow
Katrina: 绝了好吗
Katrina: It's amazing, right?
其他人：来介绍一下
Others: Come on, introduce it
Katrina: 这就是我梦想中的房间
Katrina: This is the room of my dreams.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 我拍了给我妈看
Katrina: I took a picture to show my mom.
Katrina: 然后我妈只需要雇一个艺人就可以
Katrina: And my mom just needs to hire an artist.
其他人：雇人只需要雇一个艺人就可以了
Others: Just hiring an artist will do.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
其他人：yeah yeah yeah
Others: Yeah yeah yeah
Jake:J人被P人的房间震撼到了
Jake: J was blown away by P's room.
Jake:那我们下一个还是要来介绍一下
Jake: So, next, we still need to introduce...
Jake:不用好嘞
Jake: No need, alright.
其他人：好像也不需要介绍对
Others: Seems like there's no need for an introduction.
Lucia: 好像到我这边了是吧
Lucia: I guess it's my turn now, right?
其他人：足够好看并不需要额外介绍了
Others: It's good enough, no extra intro needed.
Jake:艺术品就不需要写
Jake: No need to describe the artwork.
其他人：能把这个小小马还是小狗
Others: Can you move this little horse or dog?
其他人：稍微搭一下吗
Others: Just a bit?
其他人：要不然大家可能不方便过去
Others: Otherwise, it might be inconvenient for everyone to pass.
Lucia: 希望他希望我墙上粘的这些胶没有掉
Lucia: Hope the tapes I stuck on the wall didn’t fall off.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Lucia: 啊没掉
Lucia: Oh, it didn't fall.
Lucia: 大家快看
Lucia: Everyone, look quick.
Lucia: 否则他一会就掉了
Lucia: Otherwise, it will fall soon.
Tasha: 我没看过那
Tasha: I haven't seen that.
Lucia: 这是一个地中海风格的房间
Lucia: This is a Mediterranean-style room.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 我本来没有那么好奇你
Shure: I wasn’t that curious about you.
Shure: 你这喊完之后我就想看了你知道吗
Shure: After you shouted, now I want to see it, you know?
Katrina: 怎么了这是
Katrina: What’s up with that?
其他人：：你一天夸张的
Others: You're so dramatic every day.
Katrina: 你一天夸张的好看
Katrina: You're so dramatically beautiful every day.
Jake:哇
Jake: Wow
Jake:投资人找着很开心
Jake: The investor is very happy.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 就是它的整体主色调是蓝色和白色
Lucia: The main color scheme is blue and white.
Katrina: 我把那里面2/5的经费买了一只这样的
Katrina: I spent 2/5 of the budget to buy this.
Lucia: 对就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Katrina: 卡特
Katrina: Carter
Lucia: 模仿了就是地中海地区
Lucia: It's modeled after the Mediterranean area.
Lucia: 就是可能
Lucia: Probably...
Lucia: 主要是希腊那边最常见的建筑风格
Lucia: It's mainly the most common architectural style in Greece.
Lucia: 的颜色
Lucia: And its colors.
Katrina: 好像参观海洋馆啊
Katrina: Feels like visiting an aquarium.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Katrina: 对是有一点
Katrina: Yeah, it kind of does.
Lucia: 是有一点
Lucia: Yeah, a little bit.
Lucia: 然后是用了墙贴渔网
Lucia: And then we used wall stickers and fishing nets.
Lucia: 然后用欧根纱模仿了一个海浪的形状
Lucia: We also used organza to mimic the shape of waves.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Lucia: 对然后就随时都可以看到小鱼
Lucia: Yeah, so you can see little fish anytime.
Jake:空调开了还能女孩会飞
Jake: With the air conditioning on, the fish will fly.
Lucia: 哦你说的很有道理
Lucia: Oh, you have a point.
Lucia: 要不然现在开开试试
Lucia: How about we try it now?
其他人：那请让它飞一下吧
Others: Let it fly!
Lucia: 不行这个因为我用的是那个
Lucia: No way, because I used...
Lucia: 就是那种粘性比较弱的纸
Lucia: Some paper with weak adhesive.
Lucia: 害怕在墙上留印子嘛
Lucia: I'm afraid it might leave marks on the wall.
Lucia: 所以如果风太大可能就会掉但
Lucia: So if the wind is too strong, it might fall off, but...
Lucia: 是我觉得领导这个提议非常不错
Lucia: I think your suggestion is great.
Lucia: 下次对对对
Lucia: Next time, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 回家我就把它改成强力胶哈哈
Lucia: I'll go home and use super glue, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你的呢b谢谢下楼
Lucia: Yours is... thanks, downstairs.
Jake:谢谢下楼
Jake: Thanks, downstairs.
Katrina: 下楼
Katrina: Downstairs.
其他人：他的是cyberpunk
Others: His is cyberpunk.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
其他人：cyberpunk
Others: Cyberpunk.
Jake:给大家一点
Jake: Give everyone a bit...
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:呵呵呵给点给点期待
Jake: Haha, give them some anticipation.
Jake:好吧待会碰
Jake: Alright, we'll meet later.
Katrina: 别别别哈哈哈
Katrina: No, no, no, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:我我来收拾一下
Jake: I'll clean up a bit.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我我我替你放下东西
Katrina: Hahaha, I'll put things down for you.
其他人：我我我替你放下东西
Others: I'll put things down for you.
其他人：这个屋这么多电脑
Others: This room has so many computers.
其他人：竟然是住了人的
Others: And people actually live here.
其他人：哈哈哈竟然是住了人的
Others: Hahaha, people actually live here.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
其他人：我以为是你
Others: I thought it was you.
Katrina: 你以为机房是吗
Katrina: You thought it was the machine room?
其他人：他可能是住两个人
Others: Maybe two people live there.
Katrina: 他也在里面住
Katrina: He also lives inside.
其他人：哈哈哈我以为这是个工作间
Others: Hahaha, I thought it was a workspace.
其他人：就是你负责导数据的
Others: You're in charge of importing data.
其他人：没想到这个居然住了一半生活了
Others: Didn't expect someone to be living there half the time.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Alice:好那可以看我的了
Alice: Alright, you can look at mine now.
Alice:我在边边角角
Alice: I'm on the edges and corners.
Tasha: 什么就是
Tasha: What do you mean?
Alice:别太夸张佳人
Alice: Don't exaggerate, Jiaran.
Jake: ：挺好搬上吧
Jake: It's fine, put it up.
其他人：现在还不能看
Others: Can't look at it yet.
其他人：现在还处在闲人免进的情况
Others: It's still off-limits to outsiders.
Lucia: 没掉
Lucia: Nothing fell.
Lucia: 反正我看到的部分都没掉
Lucia: Anyway, the parts I saw didn't fall.
Tasha: 好low啊
Tasha: So low.
Lucia: 这样特别好好好看哇
Lucia: This actually looks really nice, wow.
其他人：哇
Others: Wow
Tasha: 哇怎么了
Tasha: Wow, what happened?
Shure: 你快快快
Shure: Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈这是什
Katrina: Hahaha, what is this?
Lucia: 所以这个耳钉是故意漏出来的吗
Lucia: So, are these earrings intentionally exposed?
Lucia: 哇塞
Lucia: Wow.
Tasha: 我们做第二汉游客
Tasha: Let's be the second group of Han tourists.
其他人：卧槽牛逼
Others: Damn, that's awesome.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What happened?
Lucia: 好香啊嗯
Lucia: Smells so good, mm.
Katrina: 是有点
Katrina: Yeah, a bit.
Katrina: 让我这个理工科女就是残酷
Katrina: Makes me, a science and engineering girl, feel so harsh.
其他人：我的房间
Others: My room.
Katrina: 我的房间
Katrina: My room.
Katrina: 非常简约
Katrina: Very minimalist.
Katrina: 就是理工科
Katrina: Just like science and engineering.
Katrina: 你看
Katrina: Look.
Katrina: 没电脑就摆那然后倒球就睡的那种
Katrina: No computer, just placed there, and then the ball to sleep.
Lucia: 好看好看
Lucia: Looks good, looks good.
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Katrina: 看看
Katrina: Look at this.
其他人：我去哈哈
Others: Oh my, haha!
Katrina: 好好哎
Katrina: Nice, wow.
Katrina: 怎么有股桂花香的味道
Katrina: Why does it smell like osmanthus?
Alice:放了桂花香薰
Alice: I put some osmanthus aroma.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina: 不是吧
Katrina: No way.
Katrina: 太好看了
Katrina: It's so beautiful.
Alice:谢谢我去
Alice: Thank you, oh my.
Katrina: 原来你们几个偷偷的干这么大事
Katrina: So you guys secretly did such a big thing.
Katrina: 拍了以后回去跟我妈说
Katrina: I'll take a picture and tell my mom.
Katrina: 我要只疯狗
Katrina: I want a crazy dog.
Katrina: 怎么拍个全景呢
Katrina: How do I take a panoramic shot?
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 这是自己贴的吗
Katrina: Did you stick this on yourself?
Katrina: 拿美文纸对哦
Katrina: Using decorative paper, right.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 金康的参观了吗
Lucia: Did you see the Jin Kang exhibit?
其他人：连盒子的角度都是精心布置的
Others: Even the box angles are meticulously arranged.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:就是心机
Alice: It's all about the details.
其他人：每一个动作都是精心设计的啊哈哈
Others: Every move is meticulously designed, haha.
Katrina: 偶买噶哎呀
Katrina: Oh my god, wow.
Lucia: 哎呦他的房间是最早成型的
Lucia: His room was the first to be completed.
Lucia: 不用收拾
Lucia: No need to tidy up.
Lucia: 好好好
Lucia: Great, great, great.
其他人：好好好祝生活
Others: Great, great, wishing a good life.
其他人：简约是吧
Others: It's minimalist, right?
Shure: 朴朴素素就是真
Shure: Simple and plain is true.
Lucia: 好好
Lucia: Great.
Shure: 这个被子是叠过的啊大家哈哈哈
Shure: This blanket is folded, everyone, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈看看
Katrina: Haha, look at that.
Lucia: 这被子叠的好呀
Lucia: This blanket is folded well.
其他人：叠的好啊
Others: Nicely folded.
Shure: 叠的好吧
Shure: Folded well, right?
其他人：简约啊简约简约
Others: Minimalist, minimalist, minimalist.
Katrina: 我我比他多一点颜色呵呵呵
Katrina: I have a bit more color than him, haha.
Lucia: 这个他在里面吗
Lucia: Is he in there?
Tasha: 啊他说可以开门了他说可以开门了
Tasha: Ah, he said you can open the door now, he said you can open the door.
Lucia: 也在叠被子中
Lucia: Also folding the blanket.
Katrina: 一眼看出理工科
Katrina: You can tell he's a science and engineering guy at a glance.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈赛博朋克风
Lucia: Hahahaha, it's such a cyberpunk style.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈这个
Katrina: Hahahahahahahahahahahaha, this
Shure: 你怎么又把郁金香放卧室啊
Shure: Why did you put the tulips in the bedroom again?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 真花假花
Shure: Are they real or fake?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Katrina: 哈哈这
Katrina: Haha, this
其他人：这竟然是个麻将桌
Others: This is actually a mahjong table.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:是大家可以想象的到
Jake: It's something you can imagine.
Jake:我们平时的工作状态
Jake: Our usual working state.
Jake:我们平时一只手要控制8台电脑
Jake: We usually control 8 computers with one hand.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 八爪鱼这个地方甚至还能睡两个人
Katrina: The octopus here can even sleep two people.
其他人：这个地方甚至还能睡两个人
Others: This place can even sleep two people.
Lucia: 哈你那个一只手控制8台电脑
Lucia: Ha, you control 8 computers with one hand.
其他人：8台电脑是为什么
Others: Why 8 computers?
Lucia: 是有什么梗在里面吗
Lucia: Is there some joke in there?
其他人：梗在里面吗
Others: Is there a joke in there?
其他人：没有没有睡过
Others: No, never slept here.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：3个这个 地方睡过两个人
Others: Three of these places slept two people.
Lucia: 你确定你不是一只手关掉8台电脑
Lucia: Are you sure you're not turning off 8 computers with one hand?
Shure: 的
Shure: Yeah
Tasha: 哈哈哈是这么控制啊
Tasha: Hahaha, so that's how you control them.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈这么控制啊
Lucia: Hahaha, so that's how you control them.
其他人：是这么控制啊
Others: So that's how you control them.
Lucia: 你再说一遍哈哈哈
Lucia: Say it again, hahaha
Shure: 再说
Shure: Say it again.
Jake:电源键在这个位置的时候
Jake: When the power button is in this position.
Jake:是这么的样子
Jake: It's like this.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：哈哈用一只手碰掉总电源
Other people: Haha, use one hand to turn off the main power.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 按掉总电源
Katrina: Press the main power off.
Lucia: 然后他紧急把我叫出来帮他观音盘
Lucia: Then he urgently called me out to help him with the Guanyin Pan.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈有一次我不小心碰到这个键
Jake: Haha, once I accidentally hit this button.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈我按了下去
Jake: Haha, I pressed it down.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈哈没有
Katrina: Haha, no.
Jake:让让露西亚
Jake: Let Lucia handle it.
Shure: 插排的那个键
Shure: The button on the power strip.
Jake:现在把所有的都关掉
Jake: Now turn everything off.
Jake:然后我再松手离开
Jake: Then I let go and leave.
Lucia: 我觉得这个故事特别精彩
Lucia: I think this story is really exciting.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 一定要讲给大家都听听
Lucia: I have to tell everyone.
Lucia: 今天终于有机会
Lucia: Finally got the chance today.
Katrina: 他就一直摁着不敢松吗
Katrina: Did he keep pressing and didn't dare to let go?
Lucia: 了哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, yes.
Lucia: 对他一直摁着
Lucia: Yes, he kept pressing it.
其他人：你一松了就完蛋了
Other people: If you let go, it's all over.
Lucia: 摁到所有的硬盘都弹出之后他才敢挂
Lucia: He only let go after all the hard drives ejected.
Katrina: 哇有点像那种古代打仗
Katrina: Wow, it's kind of like ancient warfare.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 打仗踩到地雷
Katrina: 不客气
Katrina: You're welcome.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:你俩也是
Alice: You two as well.
Lucia: 笑死我了
Lucia: You're killing me with laughter.
Alice:这个房间的时尚单品
Alice: This room's fashion item.
Lucia: 蓬头垢面
Lucia: Disheveled and dirty.
Katrina: 蓬头垢面的
Katrina: Disheveled and dirty.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:那刚好各位把眼镜给放到这来了啊
Jake: So, everyone put their glasses here, huh?
Katrina: complete一下
Katrina: Complete it.
Jake:放到自己
Jake: Put them on yourself.
Jake:可能大家还没有就亲自的放过
Jake: Maybe everyone hasn't personally put them on yet.
Jake:大家可以找到自己的电脑
Jake: Everyone can find their own computer.
Jake:然后放到这个啊
Jake: And then place it here.